il y à des horizons qui inspire des
éclairs de génie je suis venu asseoir
chez mon oncle wii qui régissent la
louis painchaud puis je dirais enfin
spectacle puis j'aimerais se trouver un
nom desiles puis luis est un poète
commence à peine ce cirque éloize des
loisirs des lois et des éclairs de
chaleur le mois cadiens bonne idée ça
ce soir là jeannot painchaud s'est fait
sur ses buts une promesse qui a changé
sa vie je suis monté un soir de pluie en
eau des demoiselles et c'est là que je
me suis fait comme une promesse de
partir ce projet-là puma lancé à fond
là-dedans le fondateur du cirque éloize
a écouté l'appel du large et décidé de
quitter son île pour partir à la
conquête du monde et les vents étaient
favorables
en près de 30 ans 5 millions de
spectateurs ont assisté à l'une des six
mille représentations que le cirque a
donné dans 600 villes à travers le monde
mais les deux dernières années lyon
confirmé l'intuition qui lui soufflait
que le temps était venu de rentrer au
bercail l'idée de revenir tout à coup
bâtir quelque chose d'important aux
hells c'est assez puissant
émotionnellement terrain et dans la vie
il y a des petits miracles jeannot
painchaud appris que l'église à deux pas
de la maison où il a grandi où son père
a vécu et son grand-père avant allait
fermer quand j'ai appris que l'église
cherche une nouvelle vocation
c'est un
presque nouvelles révélations là c'est
là qu'est né le projet au pied des
demoiselles un centre de création et de
diffusion de 17 millions de dollars qui
comprendra à terme une trentaine
d'unités d'hébergement un gymnase une
salle de yoga un restaurant un café des
résidences d'artistes et une salle de
400 places dans l'ancienne église c'est
l'architecte marylène blain sabourin une
ancienne du cirque du soleil qui a été
mandaté pour élaborer les plans
par la vie est importante
la première phase
la conversion de l'église en salle de
spectacle pour accueillir entre ciel et
mer un spectacle qui mêle bien sûr les
arts du cirque mais aussi la musique
traditionnelle et le conte avec la
participation de cédric landry un autre
talentueux madelinots on est un peuple
de compteurs cse comme je dis souvent
quand on regarde la mer aussi cessé la
mer à perte de vue mais quand on voit
rien on voit loin c'est à dire que c'est
comme une page blanche
et samedi à la grande première les
spectateurs sont ressortis émerveillé
trop quelle est l'essence du coin
vraiment ça représente l'exil à l'éveil
de village oui le jeu ça côté du
vainqueur le village est réveillé ça
fait du bien jeannot painchaud et
l'équipe cirque éloize espère avoir créé
une nouvelle tradition madelinienne et
un attrait incontournable pour les
nombreux touristes qui viennent profiter
des beautés de l'archipel ici n'est bien
lexandre chartier radio-canada
havre-aubert aux îles de la madeleine